[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now there's a
local furniture superstore ready to help
you create your dream living space let's
head to in-style furniture
[Music]
hi i'm glenn cordero and you're here at
install furniture where you can have it
your style your way it's a furniture
super store for your dream home
[Music]
[Applause]
here at install furniture we have over
80 000 square feet of furniture options
that's everything from dining room
furniture living room bedroom children's
furniture outdoor furniture
we even have accessories and lighting
options they do everything from
traditional to contemporary and have all
the fabrics and materials you need to
make your house a home when you first
visit in style furniture you can expect
our friendly sales staff to guide you
and help you with whatever it is you're
looking for for your specific tastes
hello welcome to instyle might as well
put that friendly staff to the test
right let's go on a mission to find a
new accent chair any specific color
scheme you're looking for i just want to
pop a color maybe a little pattern
[Music]
i have a few right here
these are some patterned accents chairs
that we have
right right this is great a lot of
people a lot of people like that one
because it's like uh
it's very comfy and fluffy and fuzzy
well that was quick after you find what
you're looking for in style makes it
easy for you to take home the furniture
you want the day of
we offer same day delivery free delivery
free setup we have a lot of financing
options
with a few zero down options as well we
just make the whole process really easy
and with new furniture for your home
comes new artwork for your walls of
course the artwork really does
catch a lot of people's eyes and you
have a lot of variety in terms of topic
color scheme
you at the animals i see you know plants
and flowers i see aaliyah we have
something for everybody right yeah
exactly exactly because different
different people's homes reflect
different tastes and you won't have to
worry about this furniture superstore
having low inventory for all your black
friday holiday and dream home shopping
we're located at 2189 west craig road
unit 101 at the intersection of craig
and clayton we're open seven days a week
monday through saturday from 10 a.m to 7
p.m and sundays from 11 a.m
to 6 p.m
thank you in-style furniture superstore
for sponsoring this segment they're
located in north las vegas you will get
lost in there give them a call at
702-636-9458 or just visit
instylefurnitureinc.com and remember
their special offer they have exclusive
financing specials with zero down
payment options available and free
delivery on most purchases we'll be